christophe est bûcheron depuis 25 ans
c'est la première fois qu'il participe à
un projet d'une aussi grande envergure
est un honneur de la boîte un arbre pour
pour un édifice comme ça un plaisir la
reconstruction de la flèche à
l'identique est acté ces chaînes doivent
maintenant être abattus avant la montée
de sève à la fin de l'hiver qui les
rendraient trop humide mille d'entre eux
sont nécessaires pour fabriquer les deux
mille pièces de la nouvelle charpente 47
et 46 47 à peu près on va utiliser cette
partie là la partie du choeur est parti
du coeur alors tout le reste 1 va être
utilisée pour d'autres éléments mais
nous la partie structurelle va être
les arbres de la forêt de champrond
serviront à la reconstruction de la
flèche et du transept une tâche complexe
pour l'architecte qui était au chevet de
notre dame lors de l'incendié la pêche
encore aujourd'hui c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre pour les compagnons c'est
un des ouvrages de fer construit les
plus complexes que vous puissiez trouver
en france est un exercice qui encore
régulièrement donner aux jeunes
compagnons qui sont en train de faire
leur formation c'est le tracé du
tabouret de la fed
c'est la partie basse qui supportent
tout la flèche et on leur apprend à
tracer ce tabouret parce qu'en fait
toutes les pièces sont complexes n'a pas
de pareil
mais dans cette forêt de 1500 hectares
seuls les quelques chaînes les plus
prestigieux seront acheminés jusqu'à
paris
le premier arbre qui a été sélectionné
donc par alban il fallait une parfaite
rectitude
il fallait que les hommes sont très bien
cylindrique il fallait que le houppier
soit très bien équilibrée afin que le
coeur soit bien ou au centre de l'arbre
et puis ensuite les qualités c'est à
dire pas de ne pas de grosse broche déjà
pas de quoi de grosses de gros défauts
extérieur une fois ci et les bois
reposeront à l'abri pendant 12 à 18 mois
le chantier débutera quant à lui fin
2021 pour que notre dame renaisse de ses
cendres
d'ici 2024